I'm not sure if you guys heard about
this yet but I thought it's important
for you to hear if you have it in case
you missed it the the Second Coming
happened I don't know if you saw it but
the Second Coming did happen not a huge
deal or anything but the Second Coming
did did in fact happen a pretty highly
anticipated event almost as anticipated
as the Joker movie which is coming out
this weekend which I'm looking forward
to the Church of Sweden as it turns out
has said that climate change alarmist
Greta Thune Berg is the successor of
Jesus Christ they have appointed her as
successor of Jesus Christ which means
like I said that that her birth I guess
was in effect the second coming I don't
remember reading that that's not wasn't
my interpretation of the book of Genesis
in fact I kind of was well I was kind of
expecting more I was thinking you know
multi-headed dragons and horsemen coming
out of the sky and that's sort of how
the whole apocalypse thing would happen
but all kinds of mystical stuff but
instead we get a teenager yelling at us
for not recycling I'd be lying if I said
it wasn't a little bit disappointed two
thousand years of waiting and the new
Jesus comes on a mission to reduce
carbon emissions not exactly what we
were anticipating but what can you do
plenty to discuss today beginning with
another hate crime hoax that the media
fell for as usual hook line and sinker
and also as usual one that put people's
lives in jeopardy and we're gonna talk
about that in a second but first today's
podcast is brought to you by even
cheerio watches no matter what you
consider your style to be a quality
classic wristwatch is something that
every guy needs there's always going to
be an occasion where you want to look
sharp you want to impress and the Apple
watch you know it just isn't gonna cut
it you don't want that digital stuff
going on we're partnering with VIN share
o so you can get a truly stunning watch
and an even more impressive price
exclusive for our listeners VIN share
was offering an extra 15% off of their
exceptionally crafted watches right now
go to VIN Charo watches dot-com forward
slash Walsh
use code walls to save an extra 15% off
that's VI ncer o watches dot-com forward
slash Walsh and code walls for 15% off
VIN Charo you know they strive to be the
best value in the industry and I really
believe there are you know you're not
gonna find a better maid watch at that
price point anywhere else this is where
you're gonna find it the thing I like
about my Vinci era watch actually I've
got I got several of them now is that
they're classy they're solid watches
they don't fit doesn't feel like you're
trying to show off and be flashy it's
not that but you're also not wearing
some cheap hunk of metal on your on your
wrist this is a really well-made nice
looking watch go to finch era watches
comm forward slash walls to see my picks
from what my favorite watches are but
you can also pick your own and don't
forget to use code walls for 15% off
these watches already look way more
expensive than the art which which means
that you get your extra 15% off you know
you're really getting a good deal
that's havin charile watches comm all
right um here's an interesting question
to ponder as we get into the first topic
of the day what does it tell you about a
country if the members of the supposedly
oppressed segments of its population are
constantly inventing instances of
impression oppression what does it tell
you about a systematically racist
country if examples of systemic racism
have to be fabricated out of whole cloth
constantly I think maybe it tells you
that the oppressed populations aren't
actually oppressed which is a good thing
right that's good news that's something
to celebrate when the demand for
oppression has exceeded the supply that
is a very good indication that you don't
really have an impression problem in
your country you do have other problems
the fact that people want to be
oppressed is a cultural problem but the
problem is not systemic oppression
that's something to think about as we
continue along today now you may
remember the story of Amari Allen a
sixth-grade girl who claimed that a
bunch
of racist white boys in a Christian
school that she attends staged a brutal
racist horrific attack against her and
rather than me recounting her claim
let's take a trip down memory lane and
look at the CBS report about this
alleged incident this is from about a
week ago and this is what this is how
CNN reported it where were minister
where were anybody to protect her from
this heinous heinous crime
Cynthia Allen is overwhelmed with
frustration after learning what her 12
year old granddaughter Amari went
through on this school playground monday
you guys she me Amari is a sixth grader
at the private Emanuel Christian school
in Springfield Virginia the place where
second lady Karen pence teaches Amari
tells wusa9 she's been bullied for weeks
sometimes I think that like I don't
deserve to like be there at a school and
everything and that she says three
sixth-grade boys won't let up taking her
school lunches calling her names and
more recently an attack on the school
playground like all three around me
although she says a third student pulled
out scissors then cut her hair her
lengthy dreadlocks now hanging unevenly
like took like big chunks of my hair
just cut so that was the report and
there was at CBS but but every major
news outlet had a story like that they
were all over this story we should
mention might as well mention because
the media it mentioned it many times
that although I don't believe it was
mentioned in that report leaks I didn't
notice it Karen pence Mike Pence's wife
works at this school which is a fact
that many left-wing sites were only too
eager to point out when this story first
broke just one example here the
left-wing rag Ross story had this
headline their headline was white boys
attacked classmate and cut off her
dreadlocks at school or Mike Pence's
wife teaches and here's a headline from
another obscure
twing rag called newsweek sixth-graders
hold down classmate cut her dreadlocks a
private Christian school where Karen
pence teaches why is it necessary to tie
Mike Pence to this that's the question
now it isn't obviously except for the
before we even get to the fact that this
whole story is BS which it is by the way
that's the twist ending here but but you
know except for the fact there's no
reason to bring Mike Pence into this as
they did just because his wife works
there except for the fact that the left
has a Mike Pence obsession they have a
mike pence fever and the only
prescription is more Mike Pence they
just can't stop talking about the guy
they add they they are obsessed with him
and so they bring everything back to
Mike pencil they can and certainly they
weren't gonna let this opportunity to
drag his name through the mud go to
waste now in of course reporting that a
racist attack happened at a school where
Mike Pence's wife teaches that would be
like saying that there was an armed
robbery at a store where Barack Obama's
wife shops it's just it's irrelevant
unless there's a reason to think that
there's some connection but of course
there wasn't anyway getting as I said to
the surprise twist shock ending this was
all this was all bogus untrue the girl
made it up after the media reported this
story uncritically amplifying the claims
with zero skepticism you heard that and
I'll give you so much some more examples
in a moment but that Newsweek headline
was there were two problems with it one
is it tied Mike Mike Pence's wife Karen
pence to it but also there was no
allegedly no claims nothing like that
just said sixth-graders hold-down
classmate in Qatar dreads long
dreadlocks they just they reported that
as a fact but it was not a fact it was
made up a Mario Mario land the girl
admits now that she made it up her
grandparents issued a statement
yesterday they said partly to those
young boys and their parents we
sincerely apologize for the pain and
anxiety these allegations have caused to
the administrators and families of a
annual Christian school we are sorry for
the damage this incident has done to
trust within the school family and the
undue scorn it has brought to the school
to the broader community who rallied and
support for our daughter we apologize
from betraying your chest now I don't I
don't necessarily bright blame the the
grandparents for this as far as I know
they had nothing to do with making this
story up they were told this by their
granddaughter and they believed it and I
guess you can't really blame them for
believing it and you know the thing is I
don't really blame the girl either
because she's a kid and she made up a
story and that's what kids do she should
be punished for sure because it's a very
bad thing to do but I think the lion's
share of the blame should go to the
adults in the situation who should have
known better adults who for instance
work in the media so we've gone over how
these media vultures tried to tie Karen
pens to this tighter to this without
verifying a that it happened and B that
she had any knowledge of it or any way
to prevent it or had any association
with this event whatsoever this event
that didn't actually happen as it turns
out now a quick word from stamps.com you
know no one really has time to go to the
post office you're busy you got stuff
going on we all do who's got time for
all all the traffic and parking and
lugging your boxes around it's it's just
a hassle and it's the name of the game
here is to reduce the hassle in our
lives and that's why you need stamps
comm one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps comm
eliminates trips to the post office and
it saves you money with discounts that
you can't get anywhere but the post
office stamps comm brings all the
amazing services of the post office
right to your computer whether you're a
small business sending out invoices or
you're an online seller shipping out
products whatever it is you're doing
whatever your whatever your deal is
whatever your business is stamps comm is
there they can handle it with ease
simply use your computer to print
official use US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just hand it to you
l carrier you drop it in the mailbox and
it's as simple as that with stamps calm
you get five cents off every first class
stamp up to 40% off Priority Mail right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and also a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just
got a stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Walsh that stamps comm enter Walsh just
think about how about about about some
of these other headlines reporting on
this story originally like this from the
BBC here's here's the BBC's headline
last week white students cut off black
girls dreadlocks in Virginia they put
cutoff in quotes there but there is no
allegedly no words like claims or says
or reports just the allegation
unconfirmed reported as objective fact
right in the headline or this from the
daily of the New York Daily News
girls dreadlocks shorn off by three
sixth grade boy classmates who held her
down : family so you see what they did
there they put : family at the end as a
way to pretend that they're being
skeptical when really they weren't
because all people are gonna get a
notice is they're gonna notice the girls
dreadlocks shorn off by white boys
that's all they're gonna notice when a
media outlet is just a just a good rule
of thumb oftentimes when a media outlet
wants to report an unsubstantiated
allegation as fact but they want to do
it in a way that gives them plausible
deniability so that if it turns out so
if it's exposed as unsubstantiated or as
false they can always say hey you know
we we never said it really happen what
they'll do is they'll they'll put the
allegation in the headline and at the
very end of the headline they'll put a
colon report or : family or something
like that or even like a comma report
says so it would be like man abducted by
aliens squids from Neptune report says
well how about the website essence
says twelve-year-old girl gets her
beautiful locks cut off in school hate
crime but even the headlines that that
have appropriate qualifiers are bad like
this from an NBC affiliate says sixth
grades sixth grader says classmate cut
her dreadlocks at school where Karen
pence teaches so you've got this says in
there at least so that's good but here's
the real issue no matter how you report
it it's gonna be a problem and the real
problem is that you're reporting it in
the first place because we've seen this
movie before we've seen this movie many
times we've been through this
we know that people make stuff like this
up all the time which means that the
absence of real evidence if all we have
is he said she said then a responsible
journalist a responsible media outlet
that actually cares about the truth that
wants to and wants to do the right thing
wouldn't report the story at all so they
they always can find cover for
themselves by saying hey we didn't know
it was a fake story we she said it
happened and so we reported what she
said it and hey if it did happen it
would have been a big deal okay until
there is real evidence to report the
outlandish story told by a child without
doing any kind of due diligence or any
kind of verification is malpractice see
that this this really isn't hard when I
first heard this story I you you
probably had the same reaction as me if
because you're a thinking person unlike
our folks and media well I first heard
the story a week ago or whenever it was
and I saw the headlines my immediate
reaction was yeah right my immediate
reaction was a kind of sideways glance
said now I don't think so what I
immediately thought now I didn't say
that publicly because I didn't have
evidence and so just like you can't
report
Stan shaded allegations as fact without
evidence you also can't come out and say
oh I know for a fact that didn't happen
unless you have evidence so I'm not
gonna come out and that's and that's
that's one of the things the media knows
this right they know that they can
report the substantiated stuff and
you've got a you've got a you know a
young a child saying that she was
brutally attacked well nobody's gonna
want to come out against a child and say
no I think the girls lying no one's
gonna say that especially we don't have
any if the only reason why we think it
is just gut instinct which is what it
was for me that's not gonna be enough
it's not enough for me to come out
publicly and say I think she's lying
even though I thought she was so the
responsible thing what most of us did
what I did what most people I just
didn't say anything about it I didn't
say anything one way or another just
wait a minute because once the cops get
involved which they did here the cops
are gonna figure it out that that's you
give cops credit for this they have they
really have no trouble sniffing out
these fake hate crimes they can kind of
tell right away because with something
like this if it really happened there
should be a lot of evidence that it
happened and and there so it doesn't
take them long to sort it out
like they did here so when when we see
things like this from the beginning what
we should say to ourselves is hmm okay
here's the claim it's certainly a
dramatic claim and if this did happen
it's a horrible thing but there are two
explanations that could account for why
this claim is being made one explanation
is a group of race racist children at a
Christian school really did staged a
brutal premeditated hate crime in the
middle of the school day involving a
deadly weapon which would be the
scissors which no teachers apparently
noticed so there's that explanation or a
child made up a story which is more
likely all things being equal
if you have no evidence either way which
is more likely which is more likely to
happen in one scenario you need several
children to have done something
extraordinarily evil and on the other
scenario you need one kid to have done
something bad
but something that kids do all the time
which is make up stories obviously the
more likely scenario is the is that is
the latter scenario which doesn't mean
that the former is impossible it just
means that the the latter is more likely
but why am I even bothering to explain
this because we know that the media
knows exactly what it's doing
we know that the media it's not like
they don't know how to look into a story
or they don't know how to look into the
background of something and verify and
do their due diligence they know how to
do it
they're just selective about when they
do it so when a black girl tells a wild
story about white boys holding her down
and cutting her hair off the media will
report it without doing any background
or making any attempt to verify any
aspect of the story whatsoever but when
for example a white guy raises money for
Sick Kids then the media digs into his
past to find out what he tweeted in high
school now all the sudden they're
skeptical now all of a sudden they want
to know what's really going on so they
see that they see a white guy donating
money they say what's what's really
going on here hey if I did find out
what's going on with this guy
that's when they're interested in their
in their due diligence just just
vultures this is not a victimless crime
by the way what the media has done here
in this case is not victimless just like
it never is victimless it wasn't
victimless with the Covington Catholic
it wasn't even victimless in in in the
case of the justice Millette
hoax because what you're doing is you're
Fanning the flames of hatred you're
causing division and especially when
with this school I've talked to some of
the parents who have kids
to school I've gotten messages and
emails from them telling me what's been
going on at this school and it has been
chaos for the last week it's torn the
school apart it's brought all this
negative attention on the school there
are people online saying horrible things
about the school the people that teach
there the kids that go to school there
and I put this all on the media
I really do I put it a hundred percent
at their feet
it you know it's be honest in a way I I
feel sorry for the girl too because I
kind of doubt that she thought it would
it would get to this level I it's I
don't know what exactly led her to
making up this story but I'm sure part
of it was she wanted attention which as
I said kids make up stories for
attention all the time my kids do that
they don't do it on this level but but
you know kids do that it's something all
kids do sometimes and it's so I I say
look it's the kids are gonna act like
kids and and that's why the adults have
to be adults to protect them from
themselves so it's not even just for the
sake of the other kids at that schools
particularly the white kids who have
been framed as racist they're the
primary victims but even this girl
responsible adults would protect her
from herself and when she comes telling
this story rather than putting her all
over TV and setting her up for this
failure which is gonna haunt her now for
the rest of her life rather than that
they could have been responsible if they
really cared about her so they can't
even claim that that oh you know we're
just so against racism and we cared so
much for this girl that we we had to we
couldn't help ourselves but to come to
her defense if you really cared about
her you would use your brain and say
okay there's a good chance she's making
this up it doesn't make sense it's a
crazy story and so we're not gonna put
her all out there and set her up for
public humiliation
which is exactly what they did it's it's
it's detestable and it's not just the
media either we can't just put it on the
media's put this at the feet of the
media it goes it's a hundred percent
their fault but then it's also the fault
of the average people on social media
who see stories like this in a way you
know even they call it social media for
a reason
right in a way we're all part of the
media now if you have a social media
account you now participate in
amplifying spreading in effect reporting
these kinds of stories and so I think we
that's a responsibility we have to take
seriously and when you doesn't take a
lot of effort just to hit retweet on
Twitter Lorde hit share on Facebook but
when you do that with a story without
doing any with without without doing any
due diligence on your own part I think
when we do that there's responsibility
on us too we should also be saying we
hear a story like that we should say
hold on a second I don't know about this
yeah let's wait I could wait a little
bit I don't need it sound like I don't
need to retweet it right now everyone
else is already doing it I don't need to
retweet it I don't need to share it I
don't need to say anything about it if
it really happened well then I can I can
wait for the facts to come out I can
talk about it next week if I really feel
the need I don't need to do it right now
all right
um have you ever wondered why so many
Americans are sick and unhealthy and
overweight this is a this is a question
that we're all asking ourselves well
between the food supply and a sedentary
lifestyle Americans are in the worst
shape that they've ever been and that's
to put it mildly and that's why the team
of on staff physicians and Brickhouse
nutrition created field of greens
all right field greens this is what it
is it's an easy way for you to add
fruits and vegetables to your daily
routine because the fact is most of us
we're not we're not getting nearly
enough of that okay I can't remember the
last time that I sat down and ate like
an apple or something it's just we
enough time for it you don't think about
it Plus produce is expensive and it goes
bad and there's all kinds of problems
with it that's why you've got field of
greens field of greens is made with real
USDA organic fruits and vegetables it
also helps boost your immunity through
using antioxidants and it assists with
digestive help with prebiotics and
probiotics it's like having a doctor and
a nutrition and basically right in your
kitchen you could walk in your kitchen
they're right there they can help you
out one scoop delivers a full serving of
fruits and vegetables you just drop it
in a cup of water and you stir it you
drink it you're done and it's also great
for smoothies as well I've used it for
that it's delicious
bottom line this is real food not
extracts you'll look better you'll feel
better go to brick house walsh dot-com
and get 15% off your first order just
for trying okay that's all with the
promo code walsh that's brick house
walsh dot-com promo code walsh
a few other things here okay we need we
need to talk about something else you're
speaking of public humiliation so I I
don't usually follow the action on
Dancing with the Stars I've always been
more of an America's Got Talent kind of
guy myself to be honest personally but
but Sean Spicer former White House
spokesman back when the white white
house had spokesman and actually did
things like press conferences which they
don't do anymore
but he's he left the way now so I've
seen it and he's he's been on Dancing
with the Stars and he he keeps getting
voted through so they had another
episode last night I think and then
they're gonna do the results show
tonight I guess and he keeps getting
voted through because a bunch of Trump
fans keep voting keep voting for him
even though he's a terrible dancer um
and and don't take my word for it here
he is I think this was his performance
last night dancing I don't know what
kind of dance this is supposed to be but
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I mean I mean come on that's I've no
dancer myself but Sean Spicer he's not
even doing anything first of all he
stands there while people while other
people dance around him and then every
once in a while on occasion he'll wiggle
wiggle his body out of rhythm with
everybody else and then he and then he
starts standing there again you know
who's a better dancer
the guy from the Trudeau blackface video
yesterday he's a better Vance er in fact
in fact the other guy from the Trudeau
blackface video is a better dancer to
this guy remember him this guy is
actually very talented I think that's a
great that's a great impression of an
ostrich
but Spicer he turns me into a dance snob
and I can barely walk to the kitchen
without tripping over the couch okay
let's hope that's all uncoordinated in
clumsy I am and you know how I dance
this is how I did so this is how most
awkward white people when when you're in
a wedding or something and you're in a
position where people are dancing this
is me I'll show you I'll show you my
dance moves this is my dance move I'll
show you right now this is me this is
how I dance and sometimes what I'll even
do is if I really want to give I'm
really getting into it and I'm feeling
the rhythm then I'll add this move into
it watch this move do you see the thumb
so I'm doing a little thumb a little
head little thumb uh-huh so that's my
that's what this is me dancing at every
wedding I've ever been to this is me
dancing if people look over and they
want and they they're trying to assure
me to the dance floor
I just yeah good so that's me
that what I just did there that's better
I should be on Dancing with the Stars I
should be on Dancing with the Stars give
me a desk or a table and I'll just sit
there and this will be and I invoke me
through because if you're voting Sean
Spicer through that I should get through
on that I get the joke you're voting him
through because because he's bad I
understand that it's a that's a that's
trolling that's a tried-and-true
American tradition now this goes back to
who was the guy on American Idol I think
the the first the first he was the first
person to ever be trolled through one of
these talent competition
who was it was a guy I forget his name
terrible singer but he kept getting
voted through because it was funny that
he was bad and he was getting through so
I get it but there's something that I
think that I believe in more than
trolling and that I think is even more
American than trolling and that is
rewarding excellence I don't believe in
participation trophies Spicer is a
terrible dancer just like me even though
I'm better and in America when people
are terrible at things we let them know
it not by rewarding them ok no we we
reward EXO if you're good at something
we're going to applaud you but if you're
bad at it we are going to heap scorn and
ridicule on you and that is the American
Way that's the American Dream the
American Way of life so when you vote
Spicer throwing on Dancing with the
Stars you are you are destroying the
American Way and the American dream so I
beg you to stop it please stop it's not
right it is it is immoral immoral that's
what I say but still kind of funny so
let me before we get to emails let me
chime in for just a minute on this civil
war thing I figure I want to talk about
Dancing with the Stars first and then
we'll get to the less important matter
of the potential for in another American
Civil War I think you know talk about
civil war in fact if Spicer gets through
and wins dance with the Stars I think
there might be a civil war over that and
and for good reason but as you you heard
there's been a lot of discussion and
outrage over the last couple of days
because Trump tweeted a quote from his
Lackey Robert Jeffress saying that
impeachment will lead to to civil war
that's what Jefferson and Trump
retweeted it quoted it actually didn't
retweet quoted it and tweeted it and so
now everyone's giving their thoughts on
whether we are headed
to a civil war I've talked about this
before but let me let me give my two
cents on that I think there are two
concepts here one is that that sometimes
get conflated one is civil war and the
other is civil unrest now I think that
the latter option of civil unrest we are
we're already seeing that we're already
seeing the beginnings of that and we
have been seeing that over the last
several years we've seen riots in cities
we now we've got an Tifa you know that
is an example of civil unrest I think we
could be heading to a situation where
that becomes far more common and you see
that across the country I think very
easily we could be out of there and it's
got nothing to do with impeachment
Robert Jeffress said that were that it
because of impeachment there's gonna be
a civil war
I think that's silly that's that's
that's not going to be it but I think in
general as a culture we are moving in
that direction we're not moving to a
civil war for a number of reasons it's
not going to be a war mainly because in
the main reason is that nobody we yeah
we like to tweet and insult each other
on Twitter but a civil war is not fought
through Twitter that means you're
actually getting out there and putting
your life on the line okay which people
aren't gonna do and I'm not saying that
like I want them to like it's a
challenge that's not my point here I'm
saying that actually thankfully our
laziness and our preference for a
sedentary lifestyle where we live our
life through screens and and on the
couch that has had a lot of negative
effects but the one positive is that it
will save us from fighting a civil war
because that's what it comes down to
most people just have are gonna have no
interest if you if you know anything
about the you know the the the first
civil war or the first American Civil
War if we have to call it that you'll
know that that was fought during a time
when men were willing to sacrifice
everything and endure unimaginable
hardship
walk into a situation where death was
very very likely whether they died on
the battlefield or in most cases died of
disease or whatever else bad hygiene
everything that was something that men
were willing to do back then and that's
part of the reason why we had a civil
war well that's one of the things anyway
that made a civil war possible that's
just not the case anymore
and I do think it's kind of funny when
you've got a bunch of people on Twitter
say oh yeah I'm ready to fight a civil
no you're not you're just tweeted you're
not doing anything because at the end of
the day right you know you you've got
your shows coming on at 8 o'clock
tonight that you want to get home and
watch and that's what we care about most
now on the other hand going out and and
you know going and rioting and throwing
some rocks through through a window and
then going home back to your mom's
basement that's something that people
are willing to do doesn't take a lot of
energy doesn't take a lot of effort
there's not a lot of risk involved
especially because the police don't
really do much to stop it and don't
arrest very many people so that people
are willing to do and I think we're
gonna see more of that but not a civil
war thankfully but the primary reason
why we are headed in this direction and
why we're we are fracturing as a country
it's not it's not impeachment or any
specific thing that has anything to do
with Trump really it's that we just as a
people have nothing in common anymore
that's the problem and what people don't
understand is that Trump and everything
associated with him that is a symptom of
the underlying issue so the more that we
split apart as a country culturally
speaking it's not because of Trump he is
a symptom of that fracturing that has
already that has been happening now for
decades where we just don't have
anything in common there's nothing that
ties us together as a people as a
country America is a country that was
founded on an idea of a nail inalienable
she
rights endowed by a creator freedom
liberty all those that was the idea the
founding idea which at the founding of
our country was not perfectly expressed
and there were whole swaths of people
that were excluded from it which was bad
but that it was supposed to anyway be
the idea that brought us together and
these days not everybody believes in
that idea
there isn't one value or belief or
priority that we all share as a people
you get it you get a hundred random
Americans into a room you're not going
to be able to get a majority agreement
on anything no matter it no matter how
fundamental the issue is and so that's
where it's coming from is that we just
don't countries have to be built on some
kind of commonality and if it's not
going to be things like language a lot
of countries their commonality is
language or other you know other more
basic things like that if it's not gonna
be that for us then it has to at least
be ideas values beliefs but we don't
even have that so we don't have a common
language we don't have a common heritage
we don't have a common sort of cultural
experience
we don't have common values we don't
have common beliefs we don't have common
priorities what do we have in common
generally speaking I think I think
nothing we're living you've got the
different sides living in different
universes almost I mean it's guy to the
point now where we can't even agree on
things like what is a man what is a
woman the biological facts of life we
can't even agree on that
a really basic quick get a hundred
Americans in a room ask him a really
basic question do men have penises how
about that now even if we could all
agree that the answer is yes I don't
think you could build a country on on
that agreement but the fact that we
can't even agree on that just shows you
how bad the fracture the split is so
it's bad news it's not gonna be a civil
war for the reason that I said and also
another reason why there's not a civil
war so you don't you don't have you
don't have quite the same defined
geological boundaries that that you did
in the civil war of 1861
people in California tend to be liberal
as opposed to people in other states but
but we don't have that north/south
direct split that they did which is
another thing that's going to stop a
civil war but I do think that what we
see some of the chaos in the streets and
everything I think we're we are gonna
see more of that as time progresses
unfortunately I just don't see any way
around it it's it's easy we could all
sit around and say we need to have unity
we need to get along that's fine to say
I agree it would be great if we had it
but unify around what is the question
until you can answer that question
what are we unifying around until you
can answer that question I think there's
just no hope of there being any unity
all right let's go to emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Scott says if
natural selection is real why do custard
filled doughnuts still exist that's we
would talk about evolution in the last
several days that's maybe the best
argument against evolution anyone has
ever put forward so I give you that I
agree and there is no reason for custard
filled doughnuts to exist or for jelly
doughnuts to exist now you've touched
Scott on an issue that is very important
to me I've been talking about for a long
time and I don't understand why people
struggle with this if you're getting a
box of doughnuts for a group of people
at the office or whatever
don't waste precious real estate on
jelly and cream-filled Donuts don't do
that that because you know what because
those are always the last ones left if
you're getting into the break room and
somebody brought a box of doughnuts 45
minutes ago well you know that when you
open that box there's gonna be one stale
doughnut left and you know what it's
gonna be it's gonna be a jelly doughnut
it is every single time because that's
not the doughnut anybody wants so if
you're getting a box of doughnuts
why get doughnuts you only get 12:12
precious spots this is an important
decision and you're gonna waste one of
those spots on a jelly doughnut a
doughnut with jelly in it let me tell
you what a perfect box of doughnuts
consists of here it is this is the
correct box of doughnuts three glazed
three chocolate three chocolate frosted
and then now so now that's nine
doughnuts okay you got three left with
those final three spots you can get a
little creative you can throw something
else in you can throw a curveball but it
should be stuff that everybody likes it
should be the kind of doughnut where
someone says oh well you put one of
those in there right it should be that
kind of reaction it's kind of they
weren't expecting it it's coming out of
left field but it really there's gonna
be a fight over that doughnut because
everybody wants one of them so so what
I'm saying is with those final three
spots maybe you put a French cruller you
put a blueberry glazed you put a you put
a strawberry flop frosted okay you know
those aren't gonna be left behind
someone's gonna grab those and now you
have a perfect box of doughnuts this I
feel very strongly but it's the same
thing if you're getting pizza okay let's
say getting three large pizzas for a
group of people again you stick with the
staples if you get a little bit creative
you do it in a way that everyone's gonna
agree on you put pineapple if you get
three large pizzas and you put pineapple
on one of them there's gonna be maybe
one person in the whole group that wants
it
and so at the end you can have all this
pineapple leftover why would you waste
real estate on that it's mind boggling
let's go to email from Santiago says hi
Matt first of all if you read this on
the air because you please refer to me
by the pseudonym Santiago I have to say
if you're gonna choose a pseudonym you
can't do better than Santiago so well
done I'm a biologist and I studied
evolution for years I was pleasantly
surprised by your solid knowledge on
evolution despite not being a trained
biologist yourself the way you answered
the questions you got last week reflects
that you've actually done a good amount
of studying on this topic I particularly
loved your response to an email about
the Cambrian explosion and about complex
structures such as the AI the
theological aspects of it we're all so
interesting and you seem to know more
about it than I do
as a fellow Catholic I'm disappointed by
how many Christians think that the
theory of evolution is at odds with God
or Christianity this is what atheist
preachers like Richard Dawkins would
like to think but it is not true I worry
that this tendency for many fellow
Christians to deny valid scientific
knowledge because of a wrong
interpretation of Genesis is one of the
many reasons why Christianity is in
decline God gave us our senses and
reasons to discover the world he created
our ability to question and understand
creation is unique to us as humans among
animals it makes no sense for God to
give it to us but expect us not to
believe the logical conclusions that we
get from exploring the universe through
science to make this point here's a
quote I've seen attributed to st.
Augustine which properly synthesizes my
opinion it is a bit long so feel free to
exclude it if you read my email on the
show I'm not going to exclude it because
this is a great this is a great quote
how could I exclude Saint Agustin what
do you think I am some kind of heretic
so Agustin says usually even a
non-christian knows something about the
earth the heavens and the other elements
of this world about the motion in orbit
of the stars and even their size and
relative positions about the predictable
eclipses of the Sun and Moon the cycles
of the years and seasons about the kinds
of animals shrubs stones and so forth
and this knowledge he holds too as being
certain from reason and experience now
it is a disgraceful and dangerous thing
for an infidel to hear a christian
presumably giving the meaning of holy
scripture taking talking not
cents on these topics and we should take
all means to prevent such an
embarrassing situation in which people
show up vast ignorance in a Christian
and laugh it to scorn the shame is not
so much that an ignorant individual is
derided but that people outside the
household of faith think our sacred
writers held such opinions and to the
great loss of those whose salvation for
the for whose salvation we toil the
writers of our scriptures are criticized
and rejected as has unlearned in men if
they find a Christian mistaken in a
field which they themselves know well
and hear him maintaining his foolish
opinions about our books how there how
are they going to believe these books in
matters concerning the resurrection of
the dead the hope of eternal life and
the kingdom of heaven when they think
their pages are full of falsehoods and
on facts which they themselves have
learnt from experience and the light of
Reason reckless and incompetent expound
errs of Holy Scripture bring untold
trouble and sorrow on their wiser
brethren when they are caught in one of
their mischievous false opinions and are
taken to task by those who are not bound
by the authority of our sacred books for
then to defend their utterly foolish and
obviously untrue statements they will
call they will try to call upon Holy
Scripture for proof and even recite from
memory many passages which they think
support their position although they
understand neither what they say nor the
things about which they make assertion
great quote I think I've shared that
before in relation to other topics on
the show from Saint Agustin I could not
agree more with it and that's not to say
by the way I've gotten plenty of emails
over the last several days from
Christians who have issues with the
theory of evolution and can provide
intelligent reasons to just to maintain
some level of skepticism I disagree but
I won't deny the intelligence of it so
I'm not going to take the I personally I
don't know how Santiago meant it but I
personally would not take that quote and
apply it wholesale to every Christian
who doubts evolution for example but
Christian's who this is where I think
the quote applies and this I think is a
big problem and I agree with Santiago
that this that that this I think has
something to do with the decline of
Christianity in America when you have
Christians who seem to reject modern
science wholesale almost in its entirety
rejecting almost the entirety of geology
paleontology cosmology physics which
which unfortunately a large number of
Christians in this country do where they
hold beliefs that require them to not
only reject the the findings of all of
these fields of study without any
scientific reason to do so but to even
suggest that science is basically some
kind of conspiracy among atheists to
disprove God these are the kinds of
claims that crit that some Christians
will make I know that because I've been
I've been fielding these claims now for
four days longer than that actually and
and that is a real that's a real problem
I'm not saying it's a Salvation issue
where if you're wrong about the science
you know you're gonna go to hell I'm not
saying that I am saying though that
non-believers when they when they see
Christians rejecting science and and
creating this false competition
competition between science and religion
non-believers are gonna say oh I don't
this is this is some kind a part of that
well you're telling me if I if I want to
be a Christian I have to reject science
yeah I'm not gonna do that you're tell
me want to be a Christian I have to
reject almost everything I'm told by
cosmology physics paleontology
archaeology geology you tell me no no I
can't do that and so I agree with
Santiago I think that a lot of people
are scared away and it does contribute
to the decline because they have this
notion that science and
Jannetty are at odds and and I think
that's a mistaken notion but they get
that notion not just from what they're
told by guys like Richard Dawkins but
they get it even from some Christians
who affirm that confirm it by
essentially by essentially making the
same argument Richard Richard Dawkins
does which is that you know you can't
you can't accept science and christiana
you have to choose one that's the
Atheist argument and it really troubles
me when I see Christians that seem to
agree with it essentially all right this
is from Adam says how do you prefer to
have your steak cooked well the only
acceptable answer is our medium rare or
rare obviously if someone puts puts a
steak with no pink in front of me I will
take my steak knife and jam it into
their foot and I have done nine stints
in prison because of that well worth it
finally from KP says hi Matt please just
call me KP if you read this on the air
everyone's doing the pseudonym thing
today with you looking forward to your
fourth kid I had a question that I hope
you won't judge me for asking my wife
gave birth to our first child four weeks
ago it's been a challenge so far but we
are thrilled to have our baby with us as
we have been trying for a long time with
no success congratulations here's my
problem I find that as the dad I don't
feel myself bonding with him as much as
I thought I would I love him of course
but I thought it would be a much
stronger and more immediate attachment
instead it feels almost like it's my
wife's kid and I am the hired help
I'm worried that this means I'm a
horrible person am i well KP let me put
your mind at ease no you're not a
horrible person what well not for this
reason anyway if you're someone who for
example leaves your cart in the shopping
you know shopping cart in middle the
parking lot or gets the wrong doughnuts
then you'd be a horrible person for
different reasons but not for this what
you're feeling in relation to your kid I
think is perfectly natural I found with
all three of my born children so far
that in the early going at the very
young infant stage the babies are
literally attached to my wife most of
the time and the babies therefore don't
have the same kind of innate bye
need for me as they do for her which
isn't to say that I'm not needed or that
I have nothing to do it's just that
you're right as the dads were more in a
support role especially early on and
that's inevitable and especially if the
baby is nursing because so much of the
time is spent doing that and you can't
do that despite what we're told these
days men in fact cannot nurse and so
that just puts you either even more in
the supporting role and you know it's
also a little weird because you got to
think the mother has been carrying the
child for nine months and so there's a
bond that happens through that they've
they have been literally attached in
that case for that entire time but for
you as the dad the transition is much
more sudden where yeah your wife you
know was was you knew your wife was
pregnant but it was you weren't carrying
the child so it was you didn't have a
kid and now all of a sudden you do and
it's just like that so it's a sight it's
a very sudden change but I guarantee
that you'll find yourself bonding with
your child over time as he grows you're
your role in his life will also grow I
have no problem saying that I personally
I'm not a huge fan of the baby stage I
love my kids obviously when they're
babies but I I'm weird I guess because I
love that the two and three stage what
they call the terrible twos I love that
I think I think kids that stage are
awesome and hilarious and so I'm a big
fan of that stage so everyone has their
their preferences I suppose as parents I
think we're always beating ourselves up
we're always wondering is this normal am
I doing this right am I am I feeling the
right way am i loving my child enough am
I am i ruining their life forever
because I'm doing this or that these are
always questions that we have but I
think those questions just mean that you
care they mean you want your best the
best for your child your desire to be
bonded with your kid is is all that
matters at this point and unfortunately
sadly as we know a lot of kids are born
into families where the father has no
desire to be bonded to them the fact
that you have that desire
even if you don't feel the actual bond
itself quite to the intensity that you
want is but that's still a good news the
fact that you have it because love isn't
a feeling anyway of course as we know
it's a choice it's a sacrifice it's an
act of giving which you are already
doing so don't don't especially with the
first kid it's it's just there's all
kind especially with the first kid
especially in the first few months there
it's just there's no way to be prepared
for it and all kinds of weird things are
happening in your mind and there's a lot
of anxiety and you just you don't know
what to think or how to feel or and
you're not sleeping anyway and so it's
just a rough time you get through it
you'll be fine really
it um it'll it'll be fine in the end I
promise you that
and that's my parenting sermon for the
day coming from someone who is
absolutely not fit to be giving them but
I just did and speaking of that I'm
gonna wrap this up now because actually
to take my wife to the hospital she's
scheduled to deliver our child
tonight so I I would ask for your
prayers for that and by the time I talk
to you got a calf you days off by the
time I talk to you again we will have
four kids in this house dear God dear
God
alright but in all seriousness thank you
for all your prayers and well wishes and
I'll see you on the other side Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]
you